but we're talking juleps this morning I
think we're covering all Libations are
we not
against one oh my gosh well the Kentucky
Derby is this weekend of course in a
good mint julep can make you feel like
you're really at the races and good is
key because I've had some that are not
so good so we know who exactly can make
that Tony abugana Master mixologist the
modern mixologist if you will what's the
key here because I've had some that are
ooh sweet oh Heather you're absolutely
right they can it's the simplest most
difficult drink to make perfectly it's
really just mint sugar and really good
bourbon whiskey oh that's things we've
got this covered okay sorry we're
talking right in front of you we've got
the bourbon covered so Kentucky bourbon
of course because we're talking about
the Kentucky horse race and we have the
official bourbon of the Kentucky Derby
this is Woodford Reserve and we've got
the commemorative bottle just for you
and Sherry today thank you before we go
into it I just want to mention today is
the Kentucky Oaks and Finland India is
the official vodka of the Kentucky Oaks
and this is the Oaks Lily it's uh
Finlandia Cointreau it's fresh lemon
juice and it's like a cranberry juice
and it's it celebrates breast cancer so
isn't that pretty breast cancer of
course near and dear to your heart and
your organization here locally that
helps out bartenders
so that's incredible but for tomorrow
let's make a jewel okay okay so that
one's light and crocheting refreshing
that's for today you've got to gear up
to get ready first it's the whole
weekend yeah the Oaks today tomorrow the
Derby okay you got to start with the
right vessel so we've got some Julep
cups here and what I've done I've
already added some mint and simple syrup
already we'll put a little bit more mint
and Sherry how good are you at muddling
I'm a good mother Okay because I'm going
to judge these two Jewels okay so you're
muddling yep we're just releasing the
oils from the mint leaves into the syrup
and simple syrup is called simple syrup
why because it is just sugar sugar and
water sugar and water it's simple
equal parts sugar and water bringing
water to a boil just dissolve the sugar
oh wow all right so now you're going to
release those oils into that simple
syrup okay we're going to use pellet ice
yeah because this is going to work with
the whiskey with the cup to bring
everything together wow all right so now
you can go ahead Heather and pour oh a
nice two two and a half ounces just go
ahead now are you sure yes okay
is that about it I think that's perfect
you know better than me was that too
much for two and a half ounces is
different from everybody else's two and
a half ounces
and you just start stirring it pull it
up from the bottom look at the ice cubes
already kind of went down a little bit
right that's what you want you want the
dilution from the ice to kind of bring
the drink together okay you'll notice
that your sterling silver Jewel of cup
is starting to frost on the outside
right you need a little bit more pellet
ice oh and a little tip for you to find
pellet ice go to Sonic because Sonic
sells it
yes oh that's good I was going to say
how are you doing this okay and the ice
makes something different okay at
libertine social at Mandalay Bay we have
a machine that makes this we'll be
making Jules tomorrow so oh if you don't
want to make them at home come by
libertine social and we'll make one for
you oh this is great okay Tony we're
almost out of time I think I need more
but do we drink what you need is yes put
your straw
okay a nice big Bonnet of mint look at
that all right that is reusable this is
the sea turtle approved straw right here
and there's your nice spring mint oh huh
well I do make them strong but I'm not
complaining that is much better and not
too sweet yum that's delicious I don't
think I reached the simple syrup Tony
where's yours I'm gonna go with the here
we go Lily Cheers Cheers Run for the
Roses you guys Run for the right bourbon
okay I guess with that we go to break
we'll be right back